Eine ganz blöde Frage. Ja. Sollen wir bei dem vornehmen, sie bleiben oder sollen wir uns duzen? Ich heiße Christa.
Wie sie oder du das wollen. Ich richte mich da komplett nach Riesen.
Mir ist das auch scheißegal.
Ja dann, wir wollen uns duzen. Ich bin der Max.
Du bist der Max. Ich bin die Christa. Max, will ich los?
Das ist doch schön.
Heute im Rasenfunk.
Dann hab ich gedacht, so, jetzt kann ich es aber alle gespielt. Dann hab ich ausgeholt, da hab ich alle vor den Kopf gehauen worden. Die Funk steht so wie ich dachte, muss nicht auf den Platz gehen. Weiß ich nicht, was die Kerle sich da ausgedacht haben im DFB. Weiß ich nicht, hat uns auch nicht interessiert, uns hat nur interessiert, wir spielen Fußball. Das war unser Lebenswichtiges. Lass mich das ruhig sagen, aber es war die Zeit. Ich kann nur eins sagen, es waren die zehn schönsten Jahre meines Liebes. So war es.
Ich habe gelesen und es gibt jetzt auch zum Beispiel einen Podcast, da kommt Bärbel-Wohlleben drin vor und für die war die WM 1954, die Männer-WM, ein sehr wichtiges Ereignis. Ich habe gelesen vereinzelt, dass das bei dir auch so war. Allerdings, wenn wir jetzt so sprechen, habe ich das Gefühl, du hast dich auch schon vorher für Fußball sehr begeistert.
1954 bin ich noch leicht athleticsch gemacht. Da war die WM ja. Da bin ich noch mit einem jungen Mann. Wir waren so in einem Alter bei OSV Hörde. Du, da wird gleich das Fußballspiel übertragen. Ja, wo gehen wir denn dahin? Ja, da sagt er, warte mal ab, da ist ein Friseurladen in Hörde. Der hat im Fenster, hat der, hat der sein Fernseher entstehen.
Ja, super.
Dann haben wir beiden dahingetickt, haben uns vor die Scheibe gestellt, dann kamen immer so hin und wieder so ein paar Leute dazu. Dann haben wir da das Fußballspiel durch die Scheibe gesehen, ja. Zu Hause hatten wir keinen Fernseher, ja. Ja, ich sag ja, ich, das war eine schöne Zeit.
Aber gab es da dann zum Beispiel einen Spieler, wo du dir gedacht hast, das kann ich auch oder ich würde gerne so spielen wie der?
Ah, weißt du was? Ich wurde immer mit dem Helmut Rahn verglichen. Wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, der war natürlich auch rechtsaußen.
Der war aber nicht so schnell wie du, also Entschuldigung.
Ich weiß es nicht, die Männer sind schneller als Frauen, das ist nur mal naturbedingt so, ja. Aber er wurde auch so hervorgehoben als rechtsaußen. Und als ich in München dann mein gutes Spiel gab, machte bei dem 4-2-Sieg, machte ich zwei Tore. Und Gott, oh Gott, war die Christa auf einmal oben drauf.
Das war 57 gegen die Niederlande, das zweite ländliche.
Ja, es war... Weißt du was? Ich habe das Talent gehabt, ich habe das voll ausgenutzt. Und sonst wäre ich jetzt nicht bei dir im Gespräch. Du, das war alles wunderschön.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt der Höhepunkt sein sollte. Aber, also du hast das WM-Finale damals gesehen und kurz danach ging es ja dann auch los. 55 dann, Grün-Weiß Dortmund, Fortuna Dortmund. Was ich mich gefragt habe, wie lief denn dann eigentlich so ein Training im Park oder auf welchem Platz ihr auch immer gespielt habt?
Ach, weißt du was? Wir hatten einen Trainer, der hätte gerne mit uns trainiert. Der hat das auch ein paar Mal gemacht, aber dann hat er einen Ehekrach gehabt zu Hause. Da hat sich die Frau darüber beschwert. Die war eifersüchtig, dass er mit jungen Mädchen da trainierte. Pups, da war der Kerl nicht mehr da. Dann habe ich das an mich gerissen worden und habe so was, was ich aus der Leichtathletik hatte. Dann haben wir Leichtathletik gemacht, sind gelaufen und so weiter. So, weißt du, damit man was für die Kondition machen konnte. Ja, was sollte ich denn da noch machen auf der Wiese? Wir haben dann einfach Fußball gespielt. Jedes Mal. Wir haben nicht extra was herausgezogen. Jetzt machen wir das und das, du spielst gegen den und so.
Und wie habt ihr die Position geklärt zum Beispiel?
Du, da kann ich dir gar keine Antwort geben. Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist auch weg aus meinem Kopf. Ich weiß es nicht, ob jeder gefragt wurde, wenn mal was möchtest du spielen und so weiter. Oder was spielst du in deinem Verein? Was hast du gesagt und so? Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich gesagt habe. Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das Ergebnis war rechts außen. Und dann habt ihr eben Spiele gemacht und vor allem eben diese Spiele tun. Und ihr habt dann eben als deutsche Nationalteam gespielt. Natürlich nicht das offizielle vom DFB anerkannte. Klar, das ging ja noch gar nicht. Bis 1970 nicht. Und erst dann haben sie ja auch noch lange gebraucht. Und diese Spiele, die dann vor allem der Herr Floritz für euch organisiert hat, das waren ja dann mehrere an einem Wochenende. Ihr habt bis zu vier Mal gespielt. Zwei Mal.
Samstags und Sonntags haben wir gespielt.
Und so bist du auf insgesamt 150 Länderspiele gekommen. Es sind ja irre viele Wochen.
Zehn Jahre. Wir haben eigentlich im Sommer früher nicht gespielt. Ich glaube, warte mal, nee, ich muss mich anders ausdrücken. Wir haben im Sommer gespielt. Und dann war das bis Anfang November. Dann kam die Winzerzeit und dann fing das wieder so im März an. So summierten sich der 150 Spiele. Ja, du, jetzt muss ich mir auch noch...
Soll ich dir was holen?
Ja, pass mal auf. Also, Prost, was?
Ja, tschüss. Auf den Herrn Floritz.
Ja, mein lieber Kerl, der hat uns eigentlich verwöhnt und wir können nichts Negatives sagen. Er hat ja auch gegen den DFB gekämpft. Sonst hätte er auf kommunalen Plätzen, die erlaubt ist, gar nicht gekämpft.
Der DFB hat damals Städten, die euch haben spielen lassen, geschrieben, dass sie jetzt keine Länderspiele mehr bekommen, wenn das noch mal vorkommt. Also Steine wurden euch in den Weg gelegt, noch und nöcher.
Und Bestrafung. Ja. Und Bestrafung. Wie, weiß ich nicht, was die Kerle sich da ausgedacht haben im DFB. Weiß ich nicht, ja. Hat uns auch nicht interessiert, uns hat nur interessiert, wir spielen Fußball. Das war unser Lebenswichtiges. Lass mich das ruhig sagen. Aber es war die Zeit so.
Und wie lief dann so eine Woche ab? Also du hast gearbeitet von Montag bis Freitag im Amt dann bei der Post. Musstest manchmal Urlaub einreichen. Ich habe gelesen, es sollen sehr viele Omas gestorben sein, immer wieder und wieder.
Ja, aber die nie gelebt haben.
Genau. So habt ihr euch quasi die Freitage so hingekriegt.
Das hat doch keiner kontrolliert. Hauptsache, es war was Schriftliches da. Oma ist gestorben. Das war meine Freundin Anne, die jetzt vor zwei, nein, oder vor einem Jahr, ich weiß es nicht, muss man nachschauen, gestorben ist. Die hat das gemacht.
Sie hat einfach immer wieder ihre Oma sterben lassen, um Tag freizukriegen.
Du kannst doch nicht schon wieder die Oma sterben lassen. Ich weiß nicht, was dir da noch eingefallen ist. Oder bei den anderen. Das ist gegangen. Keiner hat die Kündigung gekriegt. Siehst du, das ist halt die Zeit gewesen, wo der Mensch nicht so war, wie er heute ist.
Na ja, bzw. eure Arbeit wurde gebraucht. Damals ganz viel des sogenannten Wirtschaftswunders ist ja von Frauen umgesetzt worden. Aber das heißt, ihr seid dann am Freitag mit dem Zug nämlich an nach Süddeutschland gefahren? Nein.
Wie ist so eine Fahrt? Wir sind nicht, ganz selten mit dem Zug. Kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Nee, wüsste ich auch nicht. Wir sind hier in Dortmund, haben einen Bus gemietet bis Oberhausen. Oberhausen stand der Bus schon. Der hat dann auch noch die Holländerin mit hineingenommen. Und wir auch.
Und jetzt seid ihr zusammen in einem Bus runtergefahren.
Mit einem Bus nach Süddeutschland.
Ach, wie war das so?
Wunderbar. Man hat nur so nebensächlich mal mit jemandem gesprochen, aber ansonsten war immer so die Scheidewand so. Wir Deutsche, wir Holländer.
Obwohl ihr so oft gegeneinander gespielt habt, haben sich da keine Freundschaften entwickelt.
Doch, da haben sich Freundschaften entwickelt. Ich glaube, die Greta-Eis-Leben, mit der ich mich da jetzt gezankt habe, die hatte eine Brieffreundschaft über den Fußball. Vor ein paar Wochen ist sie an Krebs gestorben. Sie ist auch öfter dahingefahren, hat sie besucht. Sie war auch schon ein paar Mal hier in Schwerte, wo die Eisleben wohnt. Und dann habe ich auch eine Einladung bekommen. Du komm doch mal vorbei, die, glaube ich, Ria ist die Ria, glaube ich. Die ist da. Ja, ist halt gut. Machen wir mal. Ach, das sind alles so Nebensächlichkeiten.
Aber das heißt also, ihr sitzt ab Oberhausen in diesem Bus, links das deutsche Team, rechts das holländische Team oder auch umgedreht. Und dann fahrt ihr, ja, lasst doch zum Beispiel dann dieses Spiel in München nehmen. 1957.
Moment, ich glaube, da sind wir hingeflogen. Oh, ich meine von Stuttgart. Aber wie komme ich jetzt? Ich weiß von Stuttgart nach München. Aber ich weiß nicht, was war in Stuttgart, ob wir da gespielt haben. Aber warum? Was sollte ich dann in Stuttgart oder wir in Stuttgart? Da muss man wieder trinken.
Ja, trinken in Ruhe was, ne? Waren es nicht manchmal auch zwei Städte an einem Wochenende? Weil ich habe in einem Text gelesen, aber es gibt eben leider sehr wenig über die Zeit, dass es auch den Fall gab, dass ihr Vormittags- und Nachmittagsspielen gespielt habt.
Zwei Spiele an einem Tag? Nein.
Das habt ihr nicht gemacht?
Nein, das hätten wir körperlich auch gar nicht geschafft. Das geht nicht. Du kannst da nicht erscheinen, das Höschen und Trikot an und dann trittst du da vom Ball bis schlapp im zweiten Spiel. Das lächerlich zu machen, wo wir zu kämpfen hatten. Wir wollten durch unser Können, wollten wir uns durchlavieren. Wir haben gekämpft, ja. Und wir hatten auch die Unterstützung von dem Floris, der früher glaube ich selber mal Fußball gespielt hat oder Geschiedsrichter, das weiß ich nicht. Der hat das immer prima gemacht, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, auf kommunalen Plätzen. Da waren wir immer herzlich willkommen. Manchmal war sogar eine Blasmusik da, ja. Und bevor wir einlaufen konnten, mit dem Deutschlandlied oder mit dem holländischen Lied, haben die da erst rumgeholt. Das war alles wunderschön, das passte zu uns. Wir hatten Freude und waren jedes Mal überrascht, wenn da die Musik auflief.
Und wie viele Leute waren da? Also, weil vom Spiel 1957, da ist ja bekannt, dass das richtig richtig viele waren.
18.000 oder wie viel waren da?
Genau, 18.000, sagt man.
Du, es waren immer paar Tausende da, aber München war den meisten. Ich hab in Bremen, da haben wir auch gespielt, aber da war ich nicht dabei, weil ich Urlaub angemeldet hatte und ich wusste, dass über, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich gebucht habe, ist auch nicht so lebenswichtig. Da musste ich meine Reise antreten nach Süditalien. Na ja, gut und schön. Das habe ich dann wahrgenommen, ich hätte gerne in Bremen gespielt, aber Näheres kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Aber das heißt, es waren immer ein paar Tausend Zuschauer in jeder Stadt, in der er war. Deswegen hat es sich ja auch für alle gelohnt, diese Spiele zu veranstalten.
Ja, so war das.
Und wie war das Publikum? Du hast mal in einem Interview von Feldstechern erzählt, die manche Männer mitgenommen hätten.
Die waren immer dabei. Feldstecher waren immer dabei und wie ich auch schon öffentlich sagte, was wollen die denn mit Feldstechern? Wollen sie auf deinen Busen gucken oder auf deine Knie oder auf deinen Hintern? Das war meine Äußerung, weil ich wütend war, dass die Feldstecher mitgenommen haben, um uns näher heranzuholen, was sie auch immer damit machten. Es war mir auch egal, nur ich musste meinen blöden Kommentar dazu geben, den ich auch wirklich gegeben habe. Ja, hast du schon gehört?
Aber es waren ja nicht nur Männer oder wie war das Publikum?
Ja, eigentlich durchwachsen. Es war noch, dass die Männer ihre Ehefrauen mitgenommen hatten. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen plus, minus und so. Ich sag einfach, war gut durchwachsen. Männer und Frauen, aber prozentual kann ich mich da nicht festlegen. Aber ich kann dir nur sagen, wenn du eine gute Leistung gemacht hast, da wurdest du schon während des Spiels applaudiert, habe ich oft gekriegt. Und das gibt dir irgendetwas im Inneren, du und im Kopf, du liebest halt. Was ist das denn jetzt? Du kriegst jetzt schon Applaus, hast ja noch gar kein Tor gemacht. Und wenn ich dein Tor gemacht habe, dann ging es los. Das sind alles so schöne Erinnerungen. Die nimmt dir keiner.
Also war das auch in Summe alles, weil ihr habt natürlich auch leider Beschimpfungen erlebt, Beleidigungen, Leute, die gekommen sind, um sich zu amüsieren. Aber das überwiegt bei weitem nicht so wichtig.
Du, das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Es gibt ja auch Menschen, die, wenn das Spiel schön ist, dass sie trotzdem darum meckern. Ja, aus welchem Grund auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Nein, weißt du was? Das geht uns auch nichts an. Lass die Menschen dann denken, wie sie wollen, nur sie sollen ehrlich bleiben und sollen sich da nicht wichtig durch, indem sie negativ über uns Frauen da schimpfen. Ja, das ist in jeder menschlichen Beziehung so. Das darf nicht sein. Ja, man soll ehrlich sein und sich freuen. Oh Gott, schön, dass die Mädchen Fußball spielen. So haben welche auch gesagt. Ja, man hörte das dann, wenn man angesprochen wurde nach Spielende und so weiter. Die haben sich wirklich gefreut. Die haben einen gedrückt. Und ach Gott, und waren so lieb und nett. Das kann man nicht anders bezeichnen, ob es das heute auch noch ist, glaube ich nicht. Aber die Zeit haben wir auch erlebt. Ja, das war schön.
Ja, das freut mich auch, dass es quasi eine schöne Erinnerung ist und sehr schön, dass wenige Negative dann ja offenbar in der Minderheit war. Und gleichzeitig stelle ich mir das für die Frauen im Publikum ganz besonders vor. Für dich war es etwas Besonderes zu sehen. Es gibt jetzt andere Frauen, die auch Fußball spielen, so wie ich. Und ich kann da in ein Team gehen, in einen Verein gehen. Du hast jetzt vorhin schon erzählt von einer Nürnberger Spielerin, die den Kontakt zu dir gesucht hat. Weißt du, ob das für Inspiration gesorgt hat in den Städten, in denen ihr wart?
Du, dazu kann ich mich gar nicht äußern. Und das ist so, ich glaube, so lange haben wir gar nicht korrespondiert. Die wollte nur etwas von mir wissen, was ich dann auch geschrieben habe und so weiter. Sie wollte mich auch wiedersehen. Ich sollte mal nach Nürnberg kommen und so weiter. Aber du, da hatte ich keinen Bock zu. Erst mal, nee. Da haben wir das anhören. Und dann hätte die mich bestimmt zu dieser Fußballmannschaft nach Nürnberg gebracht. Du, da hatte ich keinen Bock. Ich war noch so beschäftigt, einmal beruflich und dann ja, was man halt so bei Fortuna gemacht hat, ja. Wir haben versucht, oh, da muss ich, das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ob wir wirklich geschafft haben, zweimal die Woche trainieren. Ich will mich nicht festlegen. Also einmal ganz bestimmt, ja. Nee, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ob wir zweimal trainiert haben. Aber dadurch, dass viele Mädchen auch Verkäuferinnen waren und die nicht um halb sieben Schluss machen durften, weil sie ja noch in der Lehre waren, da mussten sie putzen. Ja, und die Zeit ist denen weggelaufen, ja. Und dann kamen sie in der Dunkelheit an. Wenn überhaupt die Möglichkeit bestand, dass sie dahingebracht wurden. Von uns hatte dann, glaube ich, gar keine Autos oder was. Ja, wir sind hier in den Vororten, wenn wir hier gespielt haben oder trainiert haben. Höschpark ist im Norden von Dortmund, hinter dem Borsigplatz. Haben wir dann da trainiert und der hat uns, dieser Rasen, der hat uns gefestigt bis zum Schluss. Dann mussten wir 65, was ich vorhin schon sagte, aufhören, weil wir keine Elfspielerin mehr zusammenkriegen. Und was ich noch sagte, zu dritt beim Notar gewesen, haben uns streichen lassen und durch die Streichung, dass es uns nicht mehr gab, wofür wir so viele Jahre gekämpft haben, haben wir erst mal geheult, als wir draußen vor der Tür standen. Das war der Schluss von meiner Fußballzeit.
1965 dann. Wie war denn das Verhältnis zu DFB, zur Stadt Dortmund, zu anderen Vereinen?
Da haben wir uns gar nicht drum gekümmert. Der Floris machte das in Süddeutschland. Das hat er immer hingekriegt. Er wird auch vielleicht Ärger gehabt haben, dass man ihn nicht für voll genommen hat oder ihn vielleicht auch rausgeschmissen hat. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wir haben nur Gutes erlebt. Und das hat uns gefreut. Viele von uns sind noch gar nicht in den Urlaub gefahren, weil sie ihr Pinky-Pinky nicht hatten, das Geld nicht hatten. Sie waren in der Lehre. Und je nachdem, was man für Eltern aushat, die konnten vielleicht auch nicht den Urlaub für ihre Tochter bezahlen. Das ist nur meine Vermutung. Ich weiß es nicht. Es war halt so, ja und...
Aber ihr seid so gut rumgekommen.
Wir sind gut rumgekommen. Ja, wir haben viel gesehen. Es war auch so, dass wir, wenn wir Nachmittags gespielt haben, dass der Flugendist jemand beauftragte und hat uns eine Stadtbesichtigung geschenkt. Ja, dann sind wir alle mal los. Und dann hat der uns, so ein Reiseführer, hat er uns durch seine Stadt geführt, was wir immer sehr herzlich aufgenommen hatten. Dass man uns sowas schenkte, ja.
Und jetzt hast du über 150 Länderspiele gemacht. Woher weißt du das? Hast du eine Liste geführt? Und kannst du mir auch sagen, wie viele Tore du geschossen hast?
Nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Schade.
Ich habe viele Tore geschossen. Aber ich weiß auch jetzt gar nicht so, dass mal vor Jahren habe ich mir die Mühe gemacht, habe die Fußballkritiken mal alle so rausgeholt.
Hast du die noch?
Ach nee, habe ich nicht mehr alle.
Oh nein, das ist doch ein Schatz. Bitte nichts davon weggeben. Wenn du es nicht mehr haben willst, schickst du es mir. Ich kenne Leute, ich habe sich die Grüße an Legende verloren. Und das Deutsche Fußballmuseum ja auch. Also die haben sich da nach die Hände.
Ja, ich habe ja auch ein gutes Verhältnis.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Gestern stand, aber habe ich ja auch schon erzählt, da hat die mich, die kam von der Theke, mich angesprochen, Kleinhans. Ich sage ja, woher kennst du mich denn mal? Ja, ich kenne dich. Na ja, gut und schön, das hast du nur nebenbei bemerkt. Aber weißt du was, es gibt so Abstriche im Leben, die du auch hast, die dir willkommen sind, wo du dich nicht drüber geärgert hast. Hast aber auch welche dabei, wo du dich mal geärgert hast. Das ist eine ganz normale Sache im Leben eines Menschen. Plus und Minus.
Aber wenn du willst, dann lass doch mal von gestern Abend davon erzählen und darüber sprechen. Du hast gestern die Exklusiv-Premiere der Doku Mädchen können keinen Fußball spielen. Gesehen, die kommt in die ARD Mediathek. Ich werde das auch verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Findet ihr alles in den Show Notes. Ein Film von Thorsten Körner, in dem ganz, ganz viele Frauen zur Sprache kommen, unter anderem eben auch du. Wie war es denn gestern?
Es war hervorragend. All diejenigen, die dem Interview standen, dann auf der Bühne. Hinter uns war die Leinwand. Entschuldigung. Und ich wurde als Erster aufgerufen, musste mich da ergeben, mit den Fragen beantworten und so weiter.
Na, da hatten sie ja gleich ein paar schöne Anekdoten auf der Bühne.
Jaja. War aber alles lieb und nett aufgezogen. Kann man gar nicht anders sagen. Ich spreche ja immer wieder, dass wir keine negative Zeit hatten. War auch gestern nicht. Es war alles wunderschön vom Thorsten Körner gemacht, der uns auch so vorstellte und immer sehr lieb und nett war zu uns. Wenn er was wissen wollte, hat er gefragt. Er war auch hier einmal schon zu Gast. Da hatte ich noch die alten Fußballspielerinnen eingeladen. Da haben wir hier fröhlich gesessen, Kaffee getrunken. Thorsten hatte Kuchen mitgebracht und hatte noch aus seiner, aus Berlin tätig. Was die für eine Funktion im Frauenfußball hat, hat er bestimmt gesagt. Ich weiß es nur nicht mehr. Die war auch sehr lieb und nett und hat sich nur Tizen gemacht. Ja, das war ein schöner Nachmittag hier. So, um auf die Situation von gestern zurückzukommen, es hat mich gefreut. Ich habe eigentlich auch damit gerechnet, dass man für das Publikum uns auch irgendwie auf die Bühne bieten würde. Und da war ich, weil ich die Alte bin, die Älteste, dass ich vielleicht als Erste rankomme. Ja, so war es dann auch. Und dann wurde eigentlich gefragt, die Fragen, die du auch gestellt hast an mich, es ist schön, dass das immer eine Wiederholung ist. Das heißt also, man wird älter, ein Kopf kann es auch nachlassen, dass du das dann nicht mehr abspeicherst. Aber wenn man so Einladungen bekommt, und du freust dich, das habe ich gestern in einem Satz auch gesagt, wenn man älter wird, dann freut man sich, wenn man wieder mal zu einem Gespräch eingeladen wird. So ungefähr habe ich mich ausgedrückt. Das musste ich da einwerfen, weil es ja auch stimmte. Ich glaube, ich bin die Älteste, auch vom Publikum her. Ist auch nur nebensächlich. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie lange ich da gefragt worden bin. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich habe eben das gesagt, was du vorhin auch fragtest, dann habe ich dann geantwortet. Und dann wurde das Gespräch weiter an die Anne-Kathrin. Moment, wie heißt sie denn?
Anne-Trabant Habach.
Ach ja, Trabach. Die hat auch lange gequatscht. Und dann zum Schluss hat die... Mensch, wie heißt sie? Geht sie jetzt noch? Mein Alter.
Vielleicht war Hannelore Ratzeburg noch dort? Ich konnte leider eben nicht vor Ort sein.
Warte mal, doch, die hat auch gespielt, aber die hat...
Es sind so viele Spielerinnen, dass ich jetzt leider nicht alle Namen hier runter ratten will. Aber wie hat dir denn der Film gefallen und was waren denn deine Gedanken dabei? Weil du im Film kommst du ja drin vor, aber relativ am Anfang, du bist quasi der Anfang einer Entwicklung und dann sieht man, welche Widerstände die Frauen nach dir zu bewältigen hatten.
Der Aufbau war gut, dass man von Anfang an, wo das Verbot bestand, dass man da die Aufnahmen machte und wie ich dir vorhin sagte, im letzten Spiel, da wo ich diesen rosa Pullover an hatte, weiß ich, hatte ich gestern nämlich nicht an. Da hat der Thorsten Körner mich auch schon interviewt, aber seine Sprache war nicht, sondern nur meine Antworten waren immer da. Da habe ich gedacht, oh, hast ja noch einen dicken Kopke.
Es ist auch immer, es ist auf Film anders, als man sich selbst sieht. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Nein, nein, es war schön. Die Zeit vor einem Jahr, die war sehr schön. Und jetzt im April durften wir nochmal wieder kommen. Da hat er uns diese Dokumentation von seinem Fußball, den hat er uns da vorgeführt. Wir sind sehr herzlich aufgenommen worden. Ich hatte die Waldrad mitgenommen und so.
Und das ist ja schön, dass die Frauen jetzt wieder eine Bühne bekommen. Und wie denkst du denn über die Entwicklung des Fußballs der Frauen nach eben deiner Zeit, die ja auch jetzt in der Doku bearbeitet wurde? Ich habe zum Beispiel gelesen, dass du den Dortmunder versuchen, Frauenfußball dann umzusetzen, erst kritisch gegenüberstand. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, ob das noch eine aktuelle Meinung von dir ist, denn die sind ja durchaus erfolgreich.
Das muss ich überlegen. Kritisch?
Na, du hast mal gesagt, die spielen dir nicht gut genug. Du gehst lieber ins Westfalen-Stadion.
Ja, habe ich das gesagt.
Aber das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Da waren ja noch ein paar Ligen, die sind ja jetzt immer aufgestiegen. Soweit jetzt ja aus der Westfalen-Liga.
Da gebe ich keinen Kommentar dazu. Mag sein, dass ich es gesagt habe. Aus welchem Grund auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Aber vielleicht war ich der Meinung, das stimmt, was du jetzt sagst. Ich habe mich da jetzt bedeckt. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mich nicht äußern.
Aber warst du mal bei den BVB-Frauen jetzt, nachdem du ja beim BVB bei den Männern eine Dauerkarte hast?
Ja, du sag mal, ich habe plötzlich eine Einladung bekommen, das war das, das ist auch wichtig für dich, das erste Frauenfußballspiel Frauenmannschaft von BVB gegen 1860 München. Ich glaube, ich weiß es auch nicht, vor zwei oder drei Jahren. Du, da hat mich der Vorstand eingeladen.
Ja, super.
Der Kramer, den kennst du ja auch. Und dann, das war der Vorsitzende, wie heißt der?
Aki Watzke.
Nein, nicht Watzke, der war gar nicht da.
Ach so.
Mein Alter kommt jetzt durch.
Und meine Unkenntnis auch. Aber der Vorstand von BVB hat ihn.
Den muss ich unbedingt erwähnen. Der hat aufgehört jetzt, der war im Vorstand. Rauball, Dr. Rauball.
Ach so, na klar. Das hätte mir aber auch einfallen müssen.
Die beiden haben mich im Stadion empfangen. Auf einmal kam eine Durchsage durch den Lautsprecher. Ja, wir begrüßen auch Christa Kleinhans, die Fußball gespielt hat. Das ist ja ganz los, voll. Und dann musste ich zu den beiden Männern hin. Die hatten mir ein Trikot geschenkt. Kleinhans stand oben drauf. Und dann hatten die so einen Spaß. Dann habe ich die erstmal geherzt, habe mich bedankt worden, dass die so nett waren und schenken mir ein Fußballtrikot. Jetzt habe ich da oben im Kleiderschrank drei oder vier von Anfang an und so. Ja, das sind alles so Sachen, die du registrierst. Und dann habe ich mir das Fußballspiel angesehen. Ja gut, ich vergleiche dann immer so, das ist nicht sportlich fair mit uns. Ich muss auch die Klappe halten. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich war nur so der Meinung, die haben nicht besser gespielt als wir damals. Damals war eine andere Zeit.
Ja, und natürlich, ihr wart dann auch allen Widerständen zum Trotz. Ihr wart im Training, ihr wart eine eingeschworene Mannschaft. Ihr erkanntet euch, ihr habt in derselben Konstellation sehr, sehr häufig gespielt. Und beim BVB damals, bei diesem ersten Spiel gegen 1860, das war ja quasi die Gründung der BVB-Frauenabteilung, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere. Da war ja damals das Bestreben des BVB, bis heute ja, das von Grund auf neu aufzubauen. Sich nicht eben die Lizenz eines anderen Vereins zu holen oder mit jemandem zu fusionieren, sondern ganz unten anzufangen. Dementsprechend können die noch nicht so lange miteinander gespielt haben.
Ich glaube, die steigern auch auf jetzt.
Ja, die sind aufgestiegen.
Die sind aufgestiegen. Und wer mich da auch noch empfangen hat, die hat gestern neben mir gesessen. Die hat, ich weiß, die auch schon über 100 Länder spiele. Mensch, wie heißt sie denn? Anne Ratke? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich halte mal die Klappe. Sehr, sehr freundlich. Die und noch eine aktive Spielerin, die haben mich gebeten, ich möchte noch nach unten kommen. Dann haben wir da auf der Laufbahn gestanden und haben uns gequatscht und wurden dann auch fotografiert. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, das war auch wieder so ein schöner Nachmittag, womit ich gar nicht gerechnet habe. Ich durfte umsonst rein.
Entschuldigung, das ist das Mindeste. Ich habe gelesen, stimmt denn die Geschichte, dass bei der WM 2011 du einen Brief geschrieben hast an Hannelore Ratzeburg, nämlich um zu fragen, ob ihr Tickets bekommt für Weltmeisterschaftsspiele und ihr nur ein Rabatt eingeräumt bekommen hättet?
Ich habe mich über die so aufgeregt, das habe ich dir auch am Telefon gesagt. Und wie habe ich gestern wiedergesehen, in Ratzeburg. Genau, aber es ist ja jetzt auch schon 50 Jahre her. Nein, das ist passé.
Aber es zeigt ja, wie euphemistisch gesagt, schwer sich der DFB bis in die jüngste Vergangenheit damit getan hat, das anzuerkennen, was Frauen wie du geleistet haben.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, was die geleistet haben. Männer aus ihrer passiven Zeit uns so nach vorne zu bringen, dass das Verbot aufgehoben wurde. Das waren eigentlich Sachen, da haben wir uns gar nicht drum gekümmert. Wir haben uns nur darum gekümmert, wann haben wir denn das nächste Spiel? Wirklich, es gab für uns nur die aktive Zeit, Fußball zu spielen, was alles in geschlossenen Räumen verhackstückt wurde, hat uns nicht interessiert. Hauptsache, uns geht es gut, man verbietet uns das nicht. Das Verbot bestand ja bis 1970, da wurde es aufgehoben. Da habe ich dann schon fünf Jahre nicht mehr gespielt. Zwischenzeitlich wurde ich zwar schon immer mal angesprochen, da zu spielen, da zu spielen, aber ich habe das immer so mit der Mannschaft verglichen, in der ich gespielt habe. Da hatte ich keinen Bock.
Du warst zu erfolgreich und deswegen konntest du nicht mehr auf eine niedrigere Runde.
Ja, war ich. Ich will nicht eingebildet sein, wenn ich das so wiedererzähle, aber das sind alles Tatsachen. Manchmal hört sich das so übertrieben an. Und 65, wie gesagt, aufgehört und dann bis 75 Handball gespielt, war auch schön. Aber jetzt vom Charakter her, der Mannschaft, hat mir die Fußballzeit besser gefallen als die Handballzeit. Wir hatten eine wunderbare, wirklich, wir hatten ja einmal, glaube ich, wir hatten auch oft Einladungen, wo wir gegen Mannschaften, die in der Bundesliga, haben die da schon in der Bundesliga gespielt, Witten hat ein Jahr, dann habe ich aber aufgehört.
In der Handball-Bundesliga, ja genau.
Habe ich aufgehört, Handball zu spielen, dann ging ich zum Kegelsport. Also ich war immer aktiv, ja.
Ja, das, auch deshalb glaube ich, können wir hier noch so ein schönes Gespräch über so lange Zeit führen. Aber was sind denn deine Gedanken zur aktuellen Stellung des Frauenfußballs? Ich muss sagen, wenn ich das mal kurz vorschieben darf, meine Perspektive, mich macht es richtig wütend, zu sehen, welchen großen Andrang es früher schon bei Spielen von Frauen gab. Und du hast es ja gesagt, es war nicht aus Häme, sondern da haben sich Leute für diesen Sport interessiert. Und dafür, dass Frauen diesen Sport eben auf einem schönen Niveau betreiben, dem man eben einfach gerne zuguckt. Und mich macht das wütend, dass dann, obwohl 1970 schon das Verbot zwar aufgehoben wurde, aber dass es dann so viele Jahrzehnte dauert, bis man, man ist ja immer noch nicht annähernd auf einer, ich will gar nicht Gleichstellung sagen zum Männerfußball, weil eigentlich kann es auch egal sein, was die Männer gemacht haben. Aber dass das so viele Jahrzehnte gedauert hat und jetzt ist zwar vieles besser geworden, aber man mag sich gar nicht ausmachen, was gewesen wäre, wäre es von Anfang an wenigstens ungefähr gleich behandelt worden.
Ich glaube, der Druck der Frauen, der Mädchen, der war so stark, dass 1970 der DFB nachgehen musste. Aber im Hintergedanken immer, irgendwann werden die aufhören. Dann werden wir die gar nicht mehr anerkennen und so weiter. Aber die wussten nicht, was das für ein Druck von unten kam. Und da musste sie natürlich helle sein wollen und haben das also dann nicht abgebrochen. Und das war dann auch die Zeit, da habe ich mich gar nicht drum gekümmert. Sollen sie noch zu sehen, wie sie da klarkommen? Verbot ist aufgehoben worden. Nun sollen sie das bringen, was sie können in der Mannschaft, dass sie weiter kämpfen, denn wir haben zehn Jahre gekämpft, wirklich gekämpft. Und die sollen auch weiter kämpfen, dass sie den Bestand behalten. Jetzt haben wir das Verbot, haben wir gebrochen, wir dürfen Fußball spielen. Weiß ich nicht, meine Gedanken. Vielleicht haben einige auch so gedacht, wir müssen Fußball spielen. Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin auch gar nicht weiter in die Vereine gegangen, um mich zu erkundigen, wie geht es euch denn, habt ihr alles gut gemacht und so weiter.
Du hast ein Stück weit abgeschlossen mit dem Fußball.
Es war abgeschlossen. Die schöne Zeit war abgeschlossen. Als wir unten waren, vom Notar, war die Fußballzeit für mich zu Ende. Ich hätte jetzt, wiederhole mich auch wieder, aber, Herr Mike Bertha, 88, diese Monate, ich möchte noch so gerne Fußball spielen. Aber es ist ein Wunschgedanke. Da sagen einige, die Alte ist bekloppt. Ja, was hat die denn jetzt schon in dem Hohen Arzt?
Aber kennst du, ich weiß gerade nicht, heißt das G-Fußball? Es gibt eine Art des Fußballs, bei der Rennen mehr oder weniger oder wirklich verboten ist. Das ist tatsächlich für Menschen, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer nur noch diese Art von Fußball spielen können. Vielleicht. Ich kenne jemanden, der spielt aus dem Bielefeld. Vielleicht kann ich euch verbinden.
Nein, nein, gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, man tickte vorher anders so. Wenn irgendetwas vorbei ist, was du geliebt hast, so habe ich gedacht. Ich will das auch jetzt so sagen. Schluss aus, feierabend. Spielst du kein Fußball mehr, obwohl ich, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, angesprochen wurde, du hast zu Fußball gespielt. Willst du nicht zu uns kommen? Ich hatte keinen Bock. Ich habe immer an unsere Mannschaft gedacht, das sagte ich vorhin auch, wie wir uns rein menschlich gut verstanden haben. Wir haben trainiert. All das, was verboten war, haben wir versucht, zu durchbrechen. Und irgendwie haben wir immer so einen Schlupf gehabt, wo wir durchbrechen konnten. Nur manchmal hat uns die Jahreszeit mit der Dunkelheit geärgert, wenn wir also frei hatten vom Beruf aus.
Das fand ich interessant. Ich habe gelesen, dass manchmal dann die Freunde und manchmal auch Ehemänner der Spielerin ihre Opel-Kapitäne an Spielverdreht haben. Und weißt du, was daran so frappierend ist an dieser Geschichte? Also die haben dann eben ihre Lichter angemacht und so hattet ihr dann Licht und konntet Fußball spielen.
Gut, dass du das sagst. Das stimmt.
Anfang der 2000er hat Katrin Lengert, die später mit dem FC Bayern, unter anderem mit dem FC Bayern auch Erfolge hatte, Torfrau war auch im Nationalteam, hat jetzt ein tolles Buch geschrieben, kann ich dir gerne mal schicken. Die hat das Anfang der 2000er auch noch erlebt. Bei Duisburg damals. Ja, aber irgendwie auch nicht schön, oder?
Ach, weißt du was? Was soll ich eine Kritik machen, von der ich nichts weiß, nicht erlebt hab, mich nicht drum gekümmert hab, kann ich nicht, ja. Ich bin nur immer der Meinung, und dabei bleibe ich. Vorher war alles anders. Ob es sportlich war, familiär anders, Ehe anders. Das kann ich alles beweisen. Ja, es war so. Wo ich dann, mich durchgesetzt hab, brauchte ich nicht bei meinen Eltern, nur bei meinem Ehemann. Und dann hab ich Schluss. Da war ich geschieden. Na ja, gut und schön. Auch das haben wir gut hinter uns gebracht. Es sind so einige Sachen, weißt du. Da freu ich mich, dass ich tatsächlich doch den Entschluss gepackt hab. Schluss aus, Feierabend. Jetzt geht's los. Scheidung. Ist eine Ansichtssache.
Und jetzt sprechen wir ja kurz bevor die Fraune im Los geht. Willst du gucken?
Ach, weißt du was? Ich bin nicht mehr so neugierig, dass ich mich so darauf freue, du guckst. Wenn ich Zeit habe, mach ich dich.
Du hast zu viele BVB-Spiele der Männer gesehen.
Die hab ich.
Die haben dir die Freude genommen. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab ja auch für die nächste Saison.
So soll es ja auch sein. Aber ich hab gelesen, dass du durchaus manchmal, auch zum Teil ja mit Anne noch, als ihr noch zusammen im Stadion wart, dass ihr doch auch durchaus mal 15 Minuten vor Ende des Spiels gegangen seid, wenn ihr gesehen habt, das wird heute eh nix mehr.
Wir gehen meistens in der 80. Minute nach Hause. Und warum? Wir fahren ja da mit dem Bus, der steht da ziemlich an der B1. Du musst also da noch ja zu Fuß vom Stadion aus, je nachdem, wie du drauf bist, 10 bis 15 Minuten. Dann stehen da die Busse alle aufgerichtet. Denn mit den Bussen sind wir in Barob, da an der Uni, sind wir eingestiegen. Und der Bus hatte uns bis zum Stadion, nicht zum Stadion, sondern da, wo er halten konnte, hat er uns hingebracht. Und das Gleiche ging dann für die Rückfahrt, ja. So war das. Und wären wir bis zum, meistens sind ja immer 3, 4 Minuten noch Verlängerung nach der 19. Minute. Das wäre alles zu voll geworden auf dem Weg zum Bus hin. Nee, haben wir gesagt, entweder gewinnen sie das Spiel oder sie kriegen gleich noch einen rein. Ja, 80. Minute, weg waren wir. Hab ich noch nie bereut. Ja, dann hörten wir im Bus schon. Da hatten einige dann das Radio an. Ich sag, wie steht's denn da? Ja, so und so. Waren wir alle zufrieden.
Aber bist du, warst du beim Spiel gegen Malaga damals im Stadion?
Ach, ich war mal in den Ausland. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich könnte ja sagen.
Weil das wäre sehr traurig, wenn du da früher gegangen wärst. Das war das, wo man dann.
Hier in Dortmund?
Ja, ja, last minute noch gewonnen. Das war, aber vielleicht ja.
Ich kann es dir ehrlich nicht beantworten. Das ist ja schon ein paar Jahrzehnte her.
Ein paar Jahrzehnte? Ja, doch inzwischen schon über ein Jahrzehnt. Aber ja, jetzt merke ich selber gerade dran, dass ich auch alt werde langsam. Ja, aber du bist im Fußball weiter verbunden, auch wenn du für dich persönlich abgeschlossen hast damit. Und ich nehme mit aus dem Gespräch. Ich erlebe dich als sehr ausgeglichen und du bist im Reinen, nicht nur mit dir, das gibt mich ja gar nichts an, wie du persönlich mit dir im Reinen bist, aber eben mit deiner Geschichte als Fußballspielerin, auch dass es dann irgendwann vorbei war und wie im Grunde dein Verhältnis zum Fußball dein Leben lang war.
Ja, meine Liebe und mein Ehrgeiz zum Fußball ist schon als Kind da. Und jetzt habe ich auch noch, sonst hätte ich keine Dauerkarte bei BVB. Und ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn sie gewinnen. Und vor allen Dingen freue ich mich mehr, wenn sie gut gespielt haben. Aber das letzte Spiel war ja wieder fürchterlich.
Welches meinst du jetzt, das letzte in der Bundesliga?
Bundesliga, Bundesliga, ach, die waren furchtbar. Das spielte alles nur im Mittelfeld, dieses Kurzpassspiel links, rechts, wieder nach hinten. Habe ich gedacht, Mensch, wann werden die Außen denn mal...
Ja klar, du wirst natürlich, dass der Rechtsaußen, der muss alle Welle bekommen, was Christa...
Die müssen bedient werden, die Linken und die Rechten. Aber das war alles nicht... Huuu, hab dich das geärgert. Na ja, gut, geh ich eben nach Hause. Ja, so sind so die Meinungen. Ich weiß nicht, ob auch so viele gedacht haben, jeder hat so seine eigene Meinung, soll er auch vertreten, wenn er meint, die ist richtig. Ja, so war das.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch drei Fragen an dich.
Tu das.
Das eine, wenn du dir, du hast dem Fußball so viel gegeben, dem deutschen Fußball, wenn du dir vom Fußball etwas wünschen könntest, was wäre das?
Was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, jetzt Fußball spielen.
Also, dass du noch mal Fußball spielen könntest?
Nochmal 70 Jahre jünger sein. Das wäre jetzt... Ach, das ist eine übertriebene Sache, übertriebene Wunschgedanke. Aber du hast mich danach gefragt, das ist eigentlich meine Antwort auf diese Frage. Würde ich gerne, ja. Vor allen Dingen, weil alles anders ist, wenn ich an die Zeit denke, wie wir zehn Jahre gekämpft haben, um überhaupt Fußball spielen zu dürfen und höhere Gewalt eben, dann war, dass wir nicht mehr bestückt waren, elf Mädchen da zusammen zu kriegen, ja. Deshalb wäre das ein Wunsch von mir, noch mal, die Mädchen können ja wunderbar Fußball spielen. Das ist ja ein Aufbau, den ich bei der Mannschaft vom BVB vermisse.
Ich meine, das deutsche Frauen-Nationalteam spielt auch Flügelastiker.
Ach, was soll man alles quaken.
Wir haben es ja alle selber gesehen. Aber ich will jetzt nicht über Nico Kovac sprechen. Wir hatten so ein schönes Gespräch.
Ich sehe nicht den Kovac.
Als Typ wunderbar. Ich glaube auch, dass er nur gute Intentionen hat. Aber ich glaube, dass er ab einem gewissen Punkt seinen Teams nicht mehr helfen kann, dabei mit Ball am Fuß einen guten Fußball zu spielen. Es ist ein pragmatischer Fußball, der auch auf ein hohes Niveau führt. Aber für das Top-Niveau, was Dortmund braucht gegen tief stehende Gegner, ich habe meine Zweifel ehrlich.
Die müssen gute Spielerinnen, gute Spieler bekommen jetzt für die nächste, im August fängt das Jahr an, für die Bundesliga zu spielen. Ich hoffe, sie kaufen gut ein. Ich weiß ja auch nicht, wen sie verlieren. Ich hoffe Bellingham, dass der seine Tore macht, wie sein Bruder.
Das sind natürlich auch große Fußstapfen. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal was anderes.
So, zweite Frage.
Die zweite Frage. Was würdest du denn der 18-jährigen Christa sagen, wenn du nochmal mit ihr reden könntest?
Mensch, Christa, hast du eine schöne Zeit verbracht. Wie lange hast du Fußball gespielt? Zehn Jahre? Und?
Na, mit 18 ist es ja noch, bevor du es spielst. Genau, du redest quasi mit der Christa, die jetzt zum ersten Mal zu Fortuna Dortmund.
Ach so, bitte nochmal die Frage.
Ja, also was würdest du der jungen 18-jährigen Christa sagen, die zu ihrem ersten Training zu Fortuna Dortmund geht?
Zum Training? Da gehe ich gar nicht hin, bei Borussia Dortmund.
Nein, nein, Fortuna Dortmund, du redest quasi mit deinem früheren selbst. Ach so. Also, was hättest du vielleicht anders gemacht oder hättest du vielleicht mehr genossen?
Weißt du was, das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann. Zeitversetz, in die heutige Zeit jetzt gelegt, denkt man anders. Denkt man anders, man fordert auch mehr von den Mädchen. Und vielleicht hätte ich das gemacht. Da kann ich dir keine ehrliche Antwort geben, weil ich das anders erlebt habe und aber auch die Zeit wirklich genossen habe. Deshalb weiß ich nicht, was hätte ich wirklich gemacht. Ich weiß es nicht. Zweite Frage war das.
Genau. Und jetzt die letzte Frage. Was würdest du den jungen Mädchen sagen, die Fußball spielen wollen? Welchen Rat würdest du denen mitgeben?
Mädchen, wenn du das Talent hast, Fußball zu spielen, kümmer dich darum, dass du in der Bundesliga einen Platz findest. Ja, guck mal, was ist denn in deiner Heimat, in deiner Stadt los? Gibt es da einen Bundesliga-Verein? Dann geh doch mal hin und guck.
Sehr gut. Christa, wir könnten noch ewig weitersprechen, aber es ist unfassbar warm und ich möchte dir jetzt eine Pause geben. Vielen, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Es hat große Freude gemacht.
Das gebe ich dir zurück. Hat mir auch Freude gemacht mit dir.
Das ist schön. Danke dir.
Das habe ich gerne gemacht.
Ja, und das war mein Gespräch mit Christa Kleinhans. Ich weiß, dass ihr Feedback zu dieser Folge haben werdet. Ich bin unheimlich gespannt darauf, das zu lesen. Ich freue mich schon sehr darauf und ich habe mir für diese Sendung etwas überlegt. Und zwar zum einen könnt ihr natürlich sehr gerne wieder unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de mir Nachrichten schicken zu dieser Sendung. Und weil ich aber weiß, dass das für Christa jetzt kein Weg sein wird, da ins Forum reinzugucken, hätte ich eine Idee. Und zwar, wenn ihr wollt, dann schickt ihr doch sehr gerne entweder per E-Mail an max.rasenfunk.de Feedback und ich drucke das dann aus. Und werdet ihr das dann zu ihrem Geburtstag am 22. Juli schicken. Oder wenn ihr sogar ein Brief oder ein Kärtchen oder sonst was loswerden wollt, dann findet ihr in den Show Notes die Adresse der Rasenfunk GmbH. Und da kann das dann hingehen. Und dann würde ich ihr als kleine Überraschung zu ihrem Geburtstag ein kleines Päckchen fertig machen. Da lege ich dann auch das Buch von Kathrin Lengardt rein. Wir verdienen mehr. Das habe ich ja auch kurz angesprochen im Interview. Und ich glaube, dass Christa sich darüber unheimlich freuen würde und auf diesem Weg dann eben auch mitbekommt, dass das hier von Leuten gehört wird. Denn, wie jetzt nicht anders zu vermuten, ist Podcast nicht das erste Medium gewesen, das ihr eingefallen wäre, wenn ich gefragt hätte, wo möchtest du denn ein Interview geben? Und logischerweise kann sie es, obwohl ich es ihr erklärt habe, wahrscheinlich auch nicht so ganz einschätzen, was wir hier eigentlich machen. Also, wenn ihr auf diese Art und Weise Feedback geben wollt, sehr, sehr gerne, entweder an max.rasenfunk.de. Das drucke ich dann aus, so wie in der guten alten Zeit. Oder ihr könnt auch gerne, wenn ihr es persönlicher haben wollt, ein Kärtchen, einen Brief, was auch immer, an die Adresse schicken, die in den Show Notes steht. Ich setze darauf, dass ihr wie immer verantwortungsvoll mit dieser Aufgabe oder diesem Angebot eigentlich umgeht. Und ansonsten kann ich euch nur empfehlen, schaut euch die Doku an. Mädchen können kein Fußball spielen von Thorsten Körner. Das ist verlinkt in den Show Notes. Und ihr könnt auch sehr gerne ins letzte Tribünengespräch reinhören. Da haben wir über einen ebenfalls ganz grandiosen Film gesprochen. Copa 71 über die WM in Mexiko 1971. Dazu ist ja das letzte Tribünengespräch erschienen. Danke auch für das tolle Feedback auf diese Sendung. Und es ist auch schön zu sehen, dass wirklich einige von euch deswegen ins Kino gegangen sind. So soll das doch sein. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und danke für euren Support. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Thorin, bei Real Hanswurst, bei Max aus Köln, bei Daklingets und bei Villa Tivoli. In diesem Sinne, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de, einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das getan haben, denn ihr wisst, ihr haltet den Rasenfunk damit am Laufen. In diesem Sinne, Feedback sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder auf dem besprochenen Weg. Abonniert sehr gerne diesen Feed hier, bewertet ihn gern, wenn ihr wollt und vor allem empfehlt doch diese Sendung auch sehr gerne weiter. Denn ich bin mir ganz, ganz sicher, sehr viele Menschen haben noch nicht von Christa Kleinhans gehört und werden sich aber, wenn sie dieses Gespräch gehört haben, ärgern, dass sie vorher noch nicht von ihr gehört haben. Das ist zumindest meine Vermutung. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, danke, dass ihr das hier möglich gemacht habt. Bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.